Randomness in algorithmica and its
implications to cryptography and
complexity so this is
um most of the talk is going to be drain
work with William kreshmer marker and
singhai and abhishekao
okay so
um I want to start the talk
by reminding our cell the the theme of
the workshop as we are coming to its end
so the theme is called minimal
complexity assumption for cryptography
and what uh what is the thing that we're
trying to investigate I think the
question is what is the minimal
complexity assumption for cryptography
um
as I have gathered so far from all the
other talks
but um but for this talk I want to take
a step back
why do we even need complexity
assumptions for cryptography
um
okay but to answer this question I have
to make it more concrete
so here's one way to make this question
concrete
why do we need complexity assumption for
some useful cryptographic task X under a
realistic model under 1989.
okay so what do I mean by useful
cryptography task X it means like things
that people use in practice so like
encryption signatures authentication
um blah blah blah
okay and now that I have added all of
these quantifiers I can tell you the
answer the answer is that if I want such
an X against polynomially bounded
adversaries then you'll need one-way
functions and once you have one-way
function then you separate MP from p and
that's a barrier
um it's for that's worth a million
dollars so you probably can't just prove
that they exist without winning a
million dollars
but you might also have noticed
something very subtle about my question
which is this year 1989.
so why what happens uh in 1989
well there's this paper by Bennett and
brazard they show that um okay so the
title is the dawn of a new era for
Quantum cryptography uh basically they
started to experiment with what is
um probably famously known as Quantum
key distribution
and they started doing experiments
showing that you can actually do uh
information theoretically secure key
distribution
um in the real world not just
um not just on paper
and obviously this year is
well it's classical crypto secure in the
real world
wow
obviously we all agree that the series
we found the Flies the experiment what
is this validate anything right because
there's no nobody okay okay good good so
the point is that
um
going back to last slide I'm talking
about a realistic model until 1989. and
the point of this slide is that when we
should consider qkd as also just as
realistic as the classical model
and obviously like it has been like 30
plus years in 1989 and like everyone can
do qkd these days right you can find it
in an average physics lab qkd
China doing qkd in the space
you can even buy a qk the commercial qkd
um from this website uh the same are not
affiliated or tested it's just funny
um on the web
okay so let's go back to this question
but instead ask what happens today in
the year 2023 so after 1989 why do we
still need computation uh complexity
assumption for doing this useful
cryptographic tasks
as we already seen qkd IR or key
distributions uh which uh what is what
qkd is supposed to be doing uh actually
do not need any complexity assumptions
um
unfortunately after the discovery of qkd
content information
theories has been looking at this
problem and they realized well actually
most of the interesting cryptographic
tasks are still unachievable if you want
information theoretic security this
includes commitment OT VC encryption
authentication blah blah blah
um and it appears that unfortunately
qkd is actually the exception not the
norm
um all the other tax still seems to
require computationally bounded
adversary you cannot get them from
information to addicts security
okay but uh let's go back to the
question which is do we still need
complexity assumptions
um it's actually not clear
um in fact we can make the question a
bit weaker for this cryptographic tests
or for which of these cryptographic
tasks do we still need say for example P
naught equal NP
okay
um
well unfortunately I don't know the
answer but in this talk I'll give you
some
um
uh progress in answering this question
and the way we give some progress to
this question is by Oracle separations
okay so for those of you that are not
very familiar formerly Oracle separation
tells you is that you will be able to
rule out a wide range of proof
techniques called relative writing proof
techniques so if you want to prove that
cryptography the existence of these
cryptographic tests implies P naught
equals to MP if you have an oracle
separation then it says that these kinds
of proof techniques cannot be used to
it's not sufficient to prove in this uh
statement yes over there uh they're a
good reason why like these two
complexity classes still instead of like
kind of peaky fever just q a or
something else
um because this is the question that is
worth a million dollars
but it's not obvious that this is like
for honest like uh Quantum crypto like
PL okay so the high level good so the
more high level we are in a Institute
that is funded by more than one million
dollars
[Music]
sorry I take it back at least a minute
[Laughter]
um but the the thing is um
um I want to reduce it to some non-berry
MP not equal to MPS are arguably one of
the biggest barrier classification or
complexity obviously there are different
other barriers like weaker bear like P
versus P space
um but uh this is like a starting point
since classical cryptography that's
right if you consider classical
constructions and sure I'll talk about
it yeah I'll talk about it but you know
if T equals to NP I can kill all the
classical cryptography so at least we
should start by investigating this
question instead of going to even New
York weaker or something instructions
why is fair to compare the peoples and
people
I'm gonna say it's fair but
um this is a this is a good starting
point you can obviously we want to like
roll out more but this is at least a
starting point
actually post content like this content
life may be bad
okay
um yeah so uh so what is the Oracle
separation that we prove
um
so the informal version is that we show
that it is possible to construct an
oracle world where uh P equals to MP so
we live in algorithmica
uh in Paglia those five worlds but still
computation is secure Quantum
cryptography is possible uh what does
this include uh specifically we'll be
constructing a form of quantum pseudo
Randomness that might have already
appeared in previous talks and as
previous talks have shown or else you
have that then you can get uh all this
nice EFI and it's friends so commitment
even black under undecodable black holes
um okay so uh before I tell you the
formal clearance statement let me first
tell you what is the opponency to learn
and that I'll be considering for this
talk yeah so uh again it's to the random
States or PRS for sure introduced by the
work of Julio and so on in 2018
and the specific specific variant that
I'll be considering for this talk is uh
from the work of morime and yamakawa
um so the
uh definition is that you have an
efficient Quantum algorithm G so we say
it is a single copy secure and qubit to
the random State generator or PRS
generator if the following true
condition holds first uh it satisfies
efficient generation so you give it a
Lambda bit input C just like a prg I
give you a sure C and then you run in
polynomial time and in the end you offer
some pure state of N qubits and I want
it to be pure just like classically I
want the PRD to be deterministic
um and so the randomness uh or a single
copies to the randomness says that uh if
I just sample a random to the random
state for a random key then if I just
give one copy of this state to an
efficient adversary a it should not be
able to tell the difference between this
state and just a uniform random bit
strings or maximum mixed States for
Content information theorets
okay and here just like classical prg
um
I require that
I require that like the length of the
output has to be longer than the length
of the input and this guarantees that
this construction will be non-trivial or
like it actually does imply EFI because
this gives you the statistical furnace
just like how you might imagine the
classical reduction goes
okay any question about this definition
um yeah so you can also consider the
many copies secure variant where the
adversary can get any number of copies
of this state and uh and the statistical
distribution that you are asked to mimic
if the N copies of or Teacups are some
high random mistakes
but for this talk we will be mostly
focused on single copy secure where we
are just trying to mimic random distance
okay so after seeing this definition you
might have a very natural question which
is that um
how is it possible to actually have a
separation
um
so for example you can say
can't I have a maybe a qma adversary for
breaking Cedar random States
um
so how does this adversary work
um the average uh so it's a qma so
there's a Merlin and an author uh Merlin
will just send Arthur that what is the c
that was used to generate uh uh this to
the random state so I said learning
sense K and then author just can just
check that the input state that he got
was the the correct City random State uh
with CK
right
um unfortunately there is an issue which
is that this is actually not exactly the
syntax of qma even because uh here
Arthur has has input a Quantum State and
you cannot just ask a qma Oracle to
decide some something for you if uh you
the the question you're asking them is
not encoded in a classical District
um and in fact uh this is somewhat
inherent as uh as we'll show we'll show
uh in the Oracle separations
okay so uh let me go back to what we've
shown in this work more formally
um
so first of all just to recall
um in the Blackhawk setting so you're
using only relative ID improved
techniques we can show that if you have
post Quantum One Way function then you
can construct even many copies secures
to the random States and once you have
those uh you can have EFI and a lot of
other stuff and all of these are only
proven uh so they are Oracle friendly or
only using a relative wise improved
techniques
and uh what we show formally is that
there is a classical Oracle
um relative to which single copy
security random States exists uh but on
the other hand P equals MP and in fact
uh P equals pH where pH is just at the
point the closure of MP
um
uh and let me also mention that uh in
the prior work by customer uh there is a
complementary theorem uh that is shown
uh which says that there is a Quantum
Oracle relative to which uh uh so what
what they get is slightly stronger so
they get many copies secure to the
random States uh and on the other hand
um bqp equals qma
okay
um so let me just uh
maybe quickly justify why we have to
like spend this effort to
prove a different theorem when we
already have k21 so why why why you
don't case anyone already conclusive
enough
um
uh there are a few reasons a few the
first reason is that uh the the
separation of k21 is a little bit
cheating
um because uh if you want to separate
um One Way functions from Quantum
cryptography then if and if you are
using a Quantum Oracle then it's
kind of maybe obvious that one-way
functions still do not exist because you
have a Quantum Oracle and if you are a
classical computer you can actually
never make use of this Quantum Oracle so
um so of course there is a Quantum
Advantage just because Quantum algorithm
can cover this Oracle whereas the
classical algorithm cannot
um and uh okay so that's a little bit
intuitive reason but formally
um the reason there is another reason
which is that if you only have a Quantum
Oracle separation uh it is actually
weaker than a classical Oracle
separation in particular uh Quantum
Oracle separations only rule out
quantumly relatively improved techniques
and that is like a strictly smaller set
of General relative surviving proof
techniques and erinson in this work has
shown that there is a counter example so
there is some Quantum Oracle separation
that fails uh for any classical Oracle
saturation
or relative to any classical Oracle
okay
um
the third reason is that uh the k21
separation actually does not have a uh
much implication to how to instantiate
Quantum cryptography in the real world
and the reason is that the way that k21
constructs PRS is just by taking a high
random Oracle which is kind of similar
to a random Oracle but for how random
unit trees and the reason why this is
problematics is because unlike random
Oracle which we can
somewhat know how to heuristically
instantiate
we have literally very little idea how
to heuristically instantiate the whole
random Oracle in fact even constructing
the pseudo-random unitary is open
whereas constructing the random function
we've known for many years
um okay finally it's a small point but
still worth pointing out we get p equals
MP in this separation whereas the prime
the other theorem gets bqp equals qma
and technically g equals MP is called
algorithmic and dqp equals qma is not
called anything
and I
and there are also Oracle separations
between each of them so they are
technically incomparable
it's basically from such a scary feeling
into one one described it probably fails
or just that there is a lot of electric
analysis
something just mixes good I'll talk
about it in the next slide
um so let me also talk about some
cryptography candidates without all my
functions so actually this is not a
complete new research directions uh
people have thought about uh what what
Quantum cryptography can you do without
relying on one-way functions although
none of those have any Oracle
separations
um at least prior to hour so this goes
back to as early as the work by kawachi
at all in 2005
um where they consider some assumptions
about some Quantum State
distinguishability problem for a
specific family of permutation steps and
they show that on the one hand it is
implied by harness of graph or the law
person on the other hand they use it to
construct Quantum pke but it is unclear
whether this is actually weaker than
what my functions
and there are also a few works okay
maybe two words that constructed uh EFI
Commandments from complexity separations
so the work that we just heard about uh
can give you EFI from uh like the worst
case assumption that vqp is not equal to
qcdk and the price there is a prior work
by uh these people where they show that
if you have a complexity separation of
qma and qip which equals P space then
you can also get common although the
catch here is that these commitments are
has auxiliary input or sometimes even
worse Corner auxiliary input meaning
that all the parties that participate in
the protocol needs to first come out
with some inefficient advice and once
you have that advice then it's secure
um there are also some folklore
construction like the one that run talk
about uh like in the Honda Supremacy
literature people have this hypothesis
that may be random Quantum circuits can
generate pseudo Randomness maybe some
almost to the random States
and in a different context uh full and
February uh
conjecture that maybe if you just
reverse engineer the Dynamics of
wormholes maybe that gives you a way to
come up with content to the random
States
um but with that said uh just to compare
uh in our work we have the first
construction that is non-trivial of
pseudo Randomness or even any Quantum
cryptography and we have a separation of
it from only functions
okay
um so without further Ado I'll now start
to talk about uh how to construct it
so the starting point of our
construction is the binary space to the
random States Construction so how does
they work so again you are given some
input c k of blender base string just
like a prg
and I'm going to consider some a family
of Boolean functions FK
um that Maps ended to one bit
and so the construction is as follows
I start by initializing n qubits in zero
I apply harder mode on all of them and
then I get 10 qubits in Plus or if you
look at it in the computational basis
it's a uniform superposition over all
the computational basic States or all
the best things
um and then what I'm going to do is uh
what's called a face Oracle uh for f f k
and what this does is that it's going to
apply in superposition so for each
computational basis State uh it is going
to apply space minus one if F sub K of X
is one otherwise it just applies to size
plus one
so in the end you get this uniform
superposition with plus minus one faces
depending on what the Boolean function
is
so that's the construction in the end
you upload this state which is an
encubus state
okay so this construction is actually
proposed back in the very first work
that proposes the random States but they
didn't prove it secure it was only
proven in the subsequent work by
requesting and shmuli they prove that
this is secure if you instantiate f-stop
case using random oracles and as a
corollary if you replace these random
oracles with pseudo-random function it
is still computationally secure
um so one naive idea to try to construct
this random state or P equals MP is that
maybe this is still secure for some f
sub K even if P equals MP
um unfortunately actually in this work
by Crusher it has already been shown
that if P equals MP then we can in fact
break all binary phased PRS for any
efficient uh F sub K so let's go back to
the the question uh earlier that it is
actually not clear like P equals MP is
actually a very low P versus MP is a
very robust question right
um
you can if the if they are equal then
you are not you are not only enrolling a
classical crypto you're also breaking
binary phase TRS so indeed it is not it
is not trivial like something can be
broken
so our work show that it is possible to
construct something that does not rely
on the harness of amp on the last bullet
except for multiple uh good yes so it is
only for multi-copy
um but we suspect our construction is
also multi-confidence secure it's just
that we couldn't prove it
um I'll talk about it later
um
right uh I guess it's not clear how to
break it with only one card
exactly that's that's what we're doing
um so we are going to use some other
Construction
okay and this is uh so we gave this
construction a name it's called T4
relation state so how does it work uh
you against uh okay but first of all
instead of one function you are going to
take key Boolean function all of them
are mapping n Bits to one bit
and you're again start with uh oldero
State and then you apply hardware and
then face Oracle on F1 but what you do
next is just to uh replace it uh redo it
a bunch of times because clearly this is
something great to do so you do again
hadamar phase Oracle for F2 so and so
forth you do these two times
but each time using a different uh
possibly different Boolean function
foreign
okay
um yeah so
you can see that how this is like a
generalization of binary phases right
because if I just set T equals one and
set F1 to be like just the same
construction before like take a random
Oracle H F1 is just h of K some input
then this is essentially recovers the
binary phase state that we had from the
last slab so uh well uh by restating the
binary phase PRS security proof we have
that one for relation State uh with f
sub 1
um
instantially like this is a random State
multi-copy secrecy random State against
bqp
um and then if you do it multiple times
and by the way this is called the
hardware face cocktail construction
because you are doing like basically
interleaving these operations and this
cute name was proposed by Scott Erickson
um okay so what happens if you do it
twice for two functions and these are
what we formally prove in the paper is
that if you instantiate F1 and F2 with
random Oracle so F1 is H of K1 input and
F2 is HK 2 of input
then uh what we show is that uh this is
remain single copy secure even for bqp
with the pH Oracle average so this is an
adversary that can query any pH
questions about this random Oracle so
certainly in this world P equals pH and
still such a construction remains single
copy secure
uh so here we are considering a specific
instantiation of using random oracles
like for example
zero then
um
yeah and uh just to uh
uh just to confirm like this K is what
is the secret in this Construction
yeah I think the the default relation
was congested in JLS already right to be
a PRS
is your conjecture like what we were
saying earlier is like the two
formulation thing uh with zero as
contactors that the one for relation
state
PRS they also had a construction of pru
I think you also yeah it is similar to
the pru construction that they propose
okay
um so we only prove that there's a
single copy secure but as I said um it's
actually only a technical issue that we
don't know how to extend it to
multi-poppies secure and plausibly our
construction is actually multi-public
secure we just don't know how to prove
it for some technical issues but
nevertheless we gave a conjecture about
T4 relation which is something that I
will tell you about in the next slide so
under that conjecture we show that t for
relation state with uh basically the
same construction but have much more
Boolean functions if in fact multi-copy
secure PRS against bqp even with the pH
Oracle
okay so uh
well it also become clear with the PHR
green superposition right yes
they can carry any pH question about the
random Oracle in superposition
you conjecture both two correlation
entities correlation of superior can
stick to the pH but you have like a more
robust conductor
yeah you can think of the T4
um
okay so certainly like that conjecture
that we put in the paper is actually
probably not true for True correlation
but nevertheless I think there uh I have
a separate conductor saying that even
without changing the construction at all
this should be secure I see but you have
like a more plausible manufacturers
well I don't know which one is more
plausible WT is like more secure in
content right yeah
you can hope that the more you do the
more secure
I think it would have a minimal
connection not the maximum
yeah so let me move on to correlation
problem so what is this correlation so
this is a problem introduced by Scott
erinson
um that uh so the original motivation is
to come up with some query uh problem
that is extremely easy for Content but
very hard for P or even MP so the the
the pro the problem is falling I gave
you an end bit Boolean function in FNG
and I want you to distinguish whether
these are sampled in the first way or
the second one so the first way is that
f is four related with G which means
that if you take the Fourier transform
of f under Boolean uh Boolean field
um this function is going to be
correlated with g
and the second case is just that there
are uniformly random so with high
probability they are not for it
and indeed in the original paper we know
that this problem is uh very easy for
pqp
um but on the other hand in the
Breakthrough result by rather than tell
it is shown that this problem is indeed
uh hard on average against pH query
algorithms
um and in the prior work by Aaronson
Ingram and kreshmer uh it is shown that
a variant of this problem called or
composed with correlation is in actually
hard on average against bqp with a pH
Oracle and uh this is will be our
starting point of our uh of our security
proof because they morally get the same
uh passive algorithm that we want
and in fact like this problem is also
very related to our Construction
um so the main idea of the security
proof is that we are going to reduce
such a problem to a new
harness property of some Boolean
function that we call hardness of
shifted correlation
um so what is this harness property it
says that if I give you a function H so
let's say you have the code to Big H
and I am going to like it's kind of
similar to the security game of prf so
think of big age is the overall prf and
H is something that you have query
access to in the prf security game so we
say big age is hard to find shifts that
hit correlation if I give the adversary
content query access to little H and
your adversaries job is just to decide
how this little Edge is sampled from one
of the two cases
the first case is that there exists some
uh some key K such that the Boolean
function h of k0 and bit input is
correlated with uh this this Boolean
function so h of K1 input X or little h
so that's the first case so okay so to
spell it out more explicitly it says
that if I take Fourier transform of H of
K 0 x over X this function is going to
be correlated with um h of K1 X X or h
of x uh
like average over X
okay and the second case is again H is
just a random function so with high
probability there is no such K that
there are afforded
um
uh okay so the the idea of our security
proof is that uh we should what we show
is the following so first of all uh we
can see that uh we can show hardness of
shift deforestation actually implies
single copy security of 24 relation
State
um um so because I I don't have much
time uh if you're interested you can
take a look at the paper
um and on the other hand we prove that
if you instantiate H with a random
Oracle then this uh the random Oracle
indeed satisfy this bqp to pH harness by
doing a reduction to uh the bqp to pH
average case hardness of oral
correlation so one technicality here is
that when we do the reduction in the end
we end up with some excretely defined
correlation distribution and we have to
basically reprove that this is Still
Remains vqp to a pH hard for this new
distribution but nevertheless we did it
but this could be something of
independent interest
okay
um
so that's about all I will say about
uh the construction and now I'll move on
to implications uh let's yes
oh you can think of or the old part is
basically the key for the all part here
we also have an old predicate here like
we're saying exist so that's morally how
or comes in
okay so let me quickly move on to the
implications so on a high level what we
have shown is that there is some harness
property for a classical hash function
called harness of shifted correlation
that's interesting because it satisfies
uh the following uh desired property
first of all such a harness property for
hash function is useful for construct
Quantum cryptography
um second uh this harness property seems
plausible because we show that it's
actually true for a random function
and finally we show that such a uh this
property is appears to be weaker than P
not equal to MP or even P naught equal
to pH at least in the Black Box setting
um and uh
you can say that
um uh similar to what the other talks
have done if you're heuristically
instantiate this construction with a
furious uh cryptographic hash like sha3
then it is possibly secure even if P
equals pH
okay so uh so here's
um if you are lost
um now is a good time to wake up and
tune in because uh here comes the
takeaway slides for the cryptographers
so as you can see
um I have impagular those five worlds
beautifully Illustrated here so the
takeaway is that our work has came along
um and we did a Thanos now and the
firewalls are saying um we don't feel so
good and they disintegrate out of
existence
okay so okay what does what does the
action mean so going back to the
question I asked from the very beginning
does cryptography need complexity
assumptions
um our Oracle separation says that for
this uh
uh practically relevant cryptographic
tasks they at least appears to be
actually independent of impagular those
five worlds
um so positively possibly not but you
can naturally the next step is to ask
what about other complexity assumption
are there any other barriers so there
are something that that is known let me
quickly summarize them uh in the work of
k21 Crash number 21 uh he showed that if
you have many copies secure pris you can
separate bqp from PP or post bqp which
is still complain contained in p-speed
so you separate P from P space so it's
still some surprise
in an upcoming work uh we use an
observation of a result by macro and
yeah
which show that if you have any
computational even quantumly falsifiable
assumption uh meaning that there are
some security game that that is
information theoretically broken but
computationally secure then you can
separate a unitary version of P from a
unitary version of P space which I will
not Define but then again this is not
actually a barrier because for all we
know we can just prove that these two
classes are in equal
um all right and it will not like cost
uh P the decision of p uh the
predecisional P from P space
so a few open questions uh if you only
have single copy secure PRS can we still
separate uh the decision of P from
decisional P space uh I think or like
even weaker things uh that's yeah five
five separation of key from P space
um and finally uh the the big question
uh asked very at the very beginning can
we just prove that Quantum cryptography
exists without assumptions period or can
we identify what are the other barriers
uh that prevent them from existing
okay
um
before I conclude the cryptographic
implications
um since this is a workshop about
assumptions following Wednesday's panel
um I would like to make a meta comment
about assumptions so here we have the
cryptographer workshops and here we have
the speaker on the left uh speaking at
the Simon Podium and she's saying let's
summon a demon excuse me I mean new
cryptographic assumption and the the
audience is like OMG this is gonna be so
far
okay uh so what's the punch line
here's what's happening at prep analyst
Workshop uh all caps who keeps summoning
um at least that's how I imagine it goes
um okay so what kind of assumption am I
going to unleash upon this world today
um okay so uh for now let us hear a word
from my sponsor Ron canary
is asking this question which asks you
to give a simple candidate instantiation
of our true formulation steps because he
hates shot three without using one-way
functions and what is the reward uh it
depends on how interesting it is that's
what he said okay so if you are
interested get in touch with ROM
an okay
foreign
there are actually natural computational
tests with content inputs and or outputs
that are actually not captured by our
current complexity Theory
um one example as uh as I've been
talking about for the past half an hour
is breaking Quantum cryptography but
there are also other natural
non-cryptographic tasks one example is
uh if you want to do a Quantum
experiment maybe you can do it faster if
you can just do it on a quantum computer
and there are also other things that
Quantum uh
computer scientists have been studying
um that that just uh they have
implicitly been considering the
computational complexity of these texts
but they are never put into a language
like the language of complexity theory
that we have today so this includes like
things like ground state preparation
tomography Quantum error correct
experience and uh like the talk this
morning recording black hole radiation
so uh
and if you look back at our separation
maybe uh
maybe this motivate that maybe we should
study the complexity for Quantum types
or even meta complexity for Content
tasks
um as like our separation is also saying
that you cannot just reduce these
problems to studying the computational
complexity of solving classical or
decisional problems
whereas classically like if P equals MP
then you get FP equals FMP and so on
um okay so since I mentioned meta
complexity let me mention one relevant
work about meta complexity so again in
the crush prior work uh he he had this
observation that if you have many copy
security random States then this
actually implies the mcsp for Quantum
States is hard just like how classical
prg implies classical mcspr
and if you look at the Oracle separation
then it says that the mcsp for Quantum
State could be hard even if bqp equals
qma so maybe we should study the
complexity of content sdsp using the
content lens
uh I mean even Quantum more than dqp
versus qms
okay but the function is that we need a
framework to talk about the
computational complexity of doing these
computational tasks
okay
um so uh so here's a quote by uh Lance
fortnite uh that he said uh just
published on his blog last month
um so I don't have much time left so you
can read it if you want but the punch
line is that uh first of all complexity
uh has uh modeled the infancy of quantum
computation cryptography randomized
parallel computations but now there's
something that our complexity Theory
does not uh capture so maybe it's time
to rethink the models
okay uh let me conclude by mentioning
some cool Works about Quantum complexity
so obviously I think they started with
the Harrison's phenomenal lecture notes
in Barbados about the complexity of
quantum State transformation and unitary
Corner State and transformation
and then in the past few years there are
a few works like let's work by Irani at
all let's start this content search
digitization reductions uh this work
that
appeared briefly before about content
algorithmic measurements which is about
accelerating Quantum experiments with
content computers
uh and there are also this recent work
that proved the content State version of
qrip equals P space and hopefully there
will be many more uh exciting works that
are coming soon about content complex
their content meta complexity okay
that's all thanks
[Applause]
to the questions before our next virtual
speaker setup
yeah so this is more of a general
knowledge question but what do you think
of like Quantum learning tasks do they
have a place in your health business
the hardness
hardness sorry
learning Quantum circles I mean yeah it
is a very interesting computational path
but I'm not sure
I think it should like we should be able
to study
I think
[Applause]